was in the middle of a dialysis session
in Khartoum when fighting broke out
around the facility
she had to rush to safety it was the
beginning of a painful journey of
displacement
by the time she made it to this
treatment center in Port Sudan she was
in serious trouble
um
my body was swollen after 15 days
without blood cleaning I would have died
if they hadn't admitted me at the center
but now the survival of the center
itself hangs in the balance every day up
to 80 patients come here for dialysis a
procedure to remove waste and excess
fluid from the blood because their
kidneys aren't working properly
the clinic is treating 250 people double
its capacity before the conflict free of
char and each patient needs two sessions
a week
it's a strain on our machines during the
past two months 11 of our 38 machines
broke down most of them use old
technology and need spare parts that we
can't get because all the stock is in
cartoon zafaran says the center is short
on stuff and running out of the special
filters and solutions needed for
dialysis treatment
without those items we'll have to close
also due to the increase in activity the
generator is overloaded it's a similar
situation at the Pediatric and cancer
hospitals government medical supplies
warehouses are nearly empty a number of
pharmacies have shut down
since the conflict began lots of Aid
organizations promised to help so we can
continue to provide free treatment to
cancer patients but we haven't received
anything Port Sudan is not the only city
facing a medical crisis the Ministry of
Health says at least 100 hospitals and
medical centers in cartoon alone have
stopped operating and the situation in
Darfur is even worse
government officials and Aid agencies
meeting here to discuss possible
solutions say providing medical
treatment is a priority but it requires
a ceasefire as well as guarantees of
safe passage for supplies and access to
those in need Muhammad van al-jazeera
Paul Sudan